le salon nautique a ouvert ses portes au
public aujourd'hui porte de versailles à
paris certains exposants se sont
spécialisés sur des créneaux
particuliers pour éviter la crise comme
nous le montre benoît vers ans et loïc
le moigne le bateau ça marche une
augmentation de 5% des ventes cette
année
du bonheur pour la plupart des
fabricants le salon c'est 30% de leur
chiffre d'affaires annuel
on ne connaît pas la crise surtout dans
le luxe et dans les niches comme ce
petit constructeur du bassin d'arcachon
qui fabrique des bateaux à l'ancienne du
bois du cuivre et des prix de 16000 à
100000 euros
les carnets de commandes sont pleins
dans notre petite niche nous sommes sont
des bateaux personnalisés nous restons à
la base un chantier artisanale qui
depuis dix ans a su s'adapter à la
demande de chaque propriétaire et en
restant dans tout ce qui est niche
il ya possibilité de tirer son épingle
du jeu en plus s'il on titille la fibre
écolo du client alors là c'est le succès
assuré
le plastique c'est bien ça permet
d'aller très vite cette technologie à la
pointe et tout ça derrière le voit ça va
nous permettre de vivre et de laisser
une planète à peu près propre pour nos
enfants et futures générations et chez
ce fabricant de kayak
on remplace le plastique dérivés du
pétrole par de la fibre de lin on passe
maintenant sur des tissus en fibre de
lin qui sont intéressantes d'un point de
vue mécanique comparable au moins ouvert
mais venant d'une ressource naturelle
entre autres fabriqué en normandie est
hissé en france nouveaux matériaux mais
aussi nouvelles façons de voyager pour
30 euros par an l'association stw
assiste le plaisancier tout au long de
son périple conseil mécanique aides à la
navigation leur site internet est une
mine d'or
lorsqu'on est loin car aujourd'hui de
plus en plus de gens partent à
l'aventuré